-My first guest tonight
is one of the
biggest stars in the world.
She's a talented
actor and producer,
who's just released her memoir,
called "Unfinished."
It is available now.
Here is Priyanka Chopra Jonas!
Priyanka,
it is so good to see you.
Look at this.
-It's so good to be back.
Real book, man. Look at that.
-Hey, by the way, not
double-spaced, not a crazy font.
-Not pictorial, not a comic.
You know, like,
real words, sentences. Damn!
-Great stories. Amazing.
I got to hop in.
I got to get into this.
I have so many questions.
You've had a
very productive quarantine.
You've had two movies.
Well, I mean, because,
you know, I'm a fan.
You've had two movies come out
on Netflix, giant hits.
You filmed two movies
and an Amazon series.
And you finished a memoir about
your life up to this point.
I'm sorry.
Some people made bread, okay?
-I was home for six months,
and that's when
the book happened,
is when I wrote --
I wrote the book
during quarantine.
But, you know,
there's so many people
watching movies and content
that, you know,
our industry is back at work.
I went back to work in October
and finished two movies.
I'm starting my new TV show.
But, you know, I'm just grateful
to be back at work, honestly.
It's been such a dreary time for
everyone, being stuck at home,
and I feel grateful
to be able to, you know,
keep creating content at a time
when people really need it.
-Yeah, exactly.
By the way, I was going to
thank you for that,
because, seriously,
we do need content,
and anyone who is
giving it to us, thank you.
We love it.
-Including you.
Thank you for
going back to the studio.
-I'm happy to talk to you.
I'm happy to talk to people.
It's just great.
And to see other people.
-People are great.
-I know.
It's like, "Oh, my gosh."
You and your husband,
Nick Jonas, who we love --
you usually travel
a lot for work.
But it must have been really
nice to have more time together.
It's, like,
really kind of interesting.
-It's amazing.
I mean,
it would have never happened.
We both have such
crazy individual careers.
I don't think
I have ever been home
for six months
in almost 25 years.
-Last time he was on,
he was showing me his
Baby Shark workout.
Dude, it's tough.
Dude, he's in great shape, man.
Do you guys work out together?
-Initially, you know,
I'm not someone
who's a fan of working out,
like most people,
but when you're married
to him, you know,
he wakes up in the morning
bright-eyed, bushy-tailed,
and he'll wear his
workout gear and go to do it.
So, you know, someone like me,
who's laying in bed
and been watching TikToks
for an hour,
is like,
"Alright, I'm just gonna --
I'm gonna get up
and try this thing."
But then he goes and makes you
do the Baby Shark workout,
and I'm thinking, like, pop
songs and we're going to dance.
And it's not easy.
I stopped -- I gave up competing
with him a long time ago.
-Yeah. I want to talk about this
book, "Unfinished."
Congratulations.
It is out today.
It became a best seller within
a day of being available
for pre-orders,
so congratulations.
It's already a best seller.
How does it feel
to finally have this out?
I mean, this is amazing stories.
How did you
remember these stories?
-I had to remind myself to
remember it, honestly.
I didn't remember a lot of it.
But having that pause during
quarantine really helped.
But, also,
it's a little strange.
You know, I've been --
I mean, I've just gotten to know
a lot of people here
in America recently.
But I've had a career in the
public eye for almost 20 years,
and I've taught myself to,
you know,
be very private and be
ferociously protective of it.
And then I do this crazy thing
and write a book.
I mean, what was I thinking?
I don't know.
-No, but they're great stories.
-I know.
-The one is, you know,
20 years ago.
You won Ms. World.
And we have
a photo of you winning.
-Yep.
-You must have a thousand things
going in your brain.
But in the book, there's a great
story about your hair.
Can we show the photo
one more time?
Why it's styled this way.
You go, "Oh, just 'cause she's
gorgeous and it beautiful."
But that's not the case.
-No, I have this
crazy tendril down my face,
and at that time,
I tried to play it cool
as if it was like a choice,
but it really wasn't.
I was trying to curl my hair,
and there was like
90 girls backstage.
Everyone is moving around
and getting their
hair and makeup done.
And I was trying to curl
my hair, and -- I don't know --
somebody jostled me, and I burnt
myself and the skin scabbed.
So I had, like, this big mark,
which I had to conceal with
concealer and that big tendril.
-And you're in the Ms. World
competition. Hello!
-Every time I look back at that
picture, I'm like,
"The choice of
the tendril -- really?"
-I think -- Well, it worked.
There's so many great stories,
and emotional stories, too,
that I love knowing about you.
But one thing that --
Just the cover.
Can you tell everyone
the story about the tattoo
right there on your wrist
or is it too --
I mean, I get emotional
thinking about it myself.
-I was very close to my father.
He was my greatest champion,
my biggest cheerleader,
like, the loudest guy
in the room.
You know, if I'd win an award,
he'd be like, "Ahh!"
And I had to tell him,
"Dad, you know,
you've got to play it cool now."
But dad didn't know how to.
He was just, like, so excited
about everything I did.
And when he died, it was just
quiet in that corner, you know?
In that corner of cheer.
-Yeah.
-Even though I have
a very supportive family,
but they weren't all as
rambunctious as him, you know?
And this tattoo was -- I got it
about a year or two before
my dad passed, and I lied
to him and I told him
I needed to write this down
because I wanted it
for artwork for my album.
But he wrote it
in his handwriting,
and it's my first tattoo.
And, you know,
now I have it here with me.
-"Daddy's lil girl..."
I just thought it's so cool
and it's a great way
to remember him.
And you know
he's rooting for you right now.
He's going crazy.
He's going like,
"Two movies and a memoir?!
You go, go, go!"
I know you're very close
with your family.
In one of the stories, to show
how supportive they were --
By the way, you look
just like your mother.
Oh, my gosh.
-I do?
-Oh, yes. Absolutely.
-Oh, that's great.
-Yeah.
-I really want to tell her that.
-I really wanted to. Thank you.
-But one of the stories --
it's towards the end --
talking about how they
let you be an individual,
even when you
were just a young kid.
There were these placards
outside of your home
where you grew up?
-You know, we lived in
a military home,
so all the houses
looked the same
and they always had,
like, nameplates,
we used to call them,
where the officers
and their names
and their designations
would be written
outside the house.
Because both my parents
were in the military,
it was, you know,
"Major Chopra,"
his designation --
MD, MBBS, whatever --
my mom's, "Captain Chopra."
And I remember when that
nameplate was being put up,
I was 5 years old, in
kindergarten at that point.
And I asked my dad,
very innocently --
I was like, "Don't I live
in this house, too?
Why isn't my name up there?"
And at 5 --
-How cute is that?
5-year-old little Priyanka
going, "Wait.
Where's my nameplate?
Do I not live here?"
-"I live here, too."
-"Do I not matter to you guys?
Hello?"
-And instead of laughing at me,
my dad said, "You are right.
We are going to
amend this nameplate."
And he wrote
"Ms. Priyanka Chopra, Upper KG"
for "kindergarten."
-Kindergarten.
I thought that was the best.
You -- Go, great, mom and dad.
I love that you did that.
It's just you.
It just shows you like,
"Hey, come on."
And they let you go,
"Yeah, you can stick up --"
I just love that story.
It's cool.
And congrats again on the book.
Your book is out.
Your memoir is out.
"Unfinished." It is out now.
Congratulations.
-Thank you so much, Jimmy.
-We always play a game
when you come on the show.
We've done every single thing.
-And you always lose.
It's so much fun.
-I almost died that one time.
I almost drowned myself.
-So did I. So did I.
-Alright, alright.
-The "Hot Ones" --
-That one was a rough one.
We've done a lot of stuff.
You almost threw yourself
through a wall once.
Do you remember that one?
-Yes.
-It was so funny.
Anyways, I wanted to play
a little game
with you now through Zoom.
Is that okay?
-Let's do it. Let's do it.
-More with Priyanka Chopra Jonas
when we come back, everybody.
Stick around.
-♪ From the smoke of
the basement to the...♪